things are gonna suck sometimes no
matter what you're never gonna avoid
that one thing that I'm particularly
good at is I'm very good at like
changing my mind about things I don't
get too attached to aspects of my
identity I don't feel committed to like
oh this is how people see me so I need
to behave that way
I think I've been good throughout my
life of like being willing to look at
myself and be like well maybe I'm not an
author maybe I just like had a good book
I'm very proud of that and it's
obviously a very important part of my
life but I don't necessarily see that as
who I am what do you see as who you are
or do you avoid that kind of statement I
avoid that statement interesting so that
you don't get trapped yes I'm an author
right now and if that one day it stops
being useful being an author I will stop
being an author